t-minus 20 seconds per stage two tanks
pressing for flight my computer has to
control the vehicle do you see anything
on the sensors that's a problem
[Applause]
baby come on baby
good night say she got
speed 1.2 km/s energy
shortly after main engine cutoff we're
going to separate the stages and begin
the second stage ignition come on
[Applause]
[Applause]
the first stage they soon begin a series
of three burns to head back towards Cape
Canaveral okay where's okay this is bad
it's mostly bad
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's done he goes coming in it sounded
like an explosion
look at this it's just sitting there
holy smokes man it's kind of amazing
that this window of opportunity is open
for life to go beyond Earth and we just
don't know how long that windows gonna
be open but the thing that gets me most
fired up is that creating the
self-sustaining civilization on Mars
would be the greatest adventure ever
ever in human history it would be so
exciting to wake up in the morning and
think that that's that's what's
happening
[Music]
[Music]